et bien bienvenue pour ce deuxième grand
prix du sénat avec jean-luc chabanon
bonjour jean luc bonjour stéphane tant
que tout nouveau grand maître
international puisque tu es de réussir
ta troisième normes de grands maîtres
tout récemment
oui donc ça c'est fait il ya pas
longtemps à montpellier donc des
commentaires de qualité on en est sûr
aujourd'hui avec donc cette première
demi finale qui va faire se voir
affronter joël lautier et laurent
frayssinet laurent fascine et qui a
choisi les pièces blanches pour démarrer
oui donc laurent frayssinet qui qui a
choisi qui n'a pas choisi ses jeux est
l'outil qui a choisi les pièces les
pièces noires pour commencer mais de
toute façon leur on préfère commencer
avec les blancs douala qui l'aurait
choisie quand même les blancs s'il avait
tué s'il avait tiré au sort
alors ici au sénat la salle est pleine
on peut dire il ya les 200 places sont
remplies on pouvait pas accueillir plus
de monde donc on a dû limiter la liste
des invités
il ya beaucoup de monde qui voulait voir
cette finale en vrai en chair et en os
en attendant sur internet vous êtes
aussi très nombreux à suivre cet
événement en direct comme d'habitude on
peut dire cette année ça va être plus
serré que l'an dernier l'un dernier à
l'excès shirov l'avait emporté il était
favori cette année c'est beaucoup plus
serré oui cette année c'est une c'est un
gros prix 100 % français puisque donc
trois jeunes les trois jeunes talents de
la génération actuelle donc joël lautier
donc en tête de liste on va dire et
christian bauer et leurs offres et
signer vont être affrontée donc on
s'affrontait avec le champion du monde
boris spassky way érection pion du monde
et finaliste l'an dernier finaliste
malheureux contre shirov mais ça a été
une super finale notamment une deuxième
partie explosifs ou ce parce qu'il avait
failli renverser la vapeur
on se rappelle de ce moment fort de l'an
dernier alors on aura sûrement des
moments forts cette année aussi
alors pour cette première partie la
outsiders c'est clairement laurent
frayssinet qui a le dernier et lé au
dernier classement elo du tas non c'est
boris spassky mais étant donné qu'il
était champion du monde on peut dire que
est forcément un hello en dessous de sa
vraie valeur il peut encore sortir des
grosses parties pourries se passe-t-il
oui donc leur offrit si pour cette
partie là qui n'est pas le favori mais
mais qui est quand même très redoutable
puisqu'on rappelle il ya il a fait
quatre points sur neuf il ya pas
longtemps tu auras d'enghien qui était
alors dix jours voilà ce deuxième grand
prix du sénat d'échecs dont je suis très
heureux de vous accueillir aujourd'hui
c'est un événement donc je suis et loire
roland je travaille pour canal web
diagonale une chaîne qui s'occupe du jeu
d'échecs et on est très heureux d'être
accueillis ici au sénat pour organiser
un tournoi d'échecs deux parties rapides
à élimination directe avec quatre
champions d'exception il y a joël
lautier laurent frayssinet christian
bauer et boris spassky le champion du
monde 1969 et 1972 donc le programme de
la journée il ya deux demi finales
aujourd'hui les finales ont lieu demain
c'est sûr le match pour la troisième
place qui était de demain matin à 10h30
la finale la grande finale demain à 14
heures voilà le programme donc tout
d'abord eh bien je vais saluer donc
demandé à mon premier invité de venir il
s'agit de yves marek donc et conseiller
technique du président du sénat on peut
applaudir tout de suite
bonjour je voudrais vous souhaiter la
bienvenue au nom du président du sénat
qui ne pas vous accueillir parce qu'il
est en ce moment chez christian bouin à
nancy mais qui nous rejoindra peut-être
demain je souhaitais tout simplement
vous dire que nous sommes heureux
d'accueillir à nouveau cet événement
puisque c'en est la deuxième édition de
nous associer à canal web et à l'équipe
de diagonale tv car nous avons de la
sympathie au sénat pour les jeunes
entreprises de la nouvelle économie
puisque nous organisons tremplin
entreprises dont canal web est également
partenaire et donc nous sommes heureux
de ce partenariat nous sommes heureux
également de continuer c'est cette
tradition qui se reproduit comme l'an
dernier avec deux différences la
première la date puisque cette année
nous organisons ça en décembre quand
vous l'avez constaté mais il paraît que
le temps sera beau demain pour la
simultanée dehors et la deuxième c'est
que le sénat a l'habitude de se
renouveler par tiers ce qui lui donne du
changement dans la continuité cette
année nous nous renouvelons pas moitié
puisque nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir boris spassky qui l'an
dernier nous a fait le plaisir de partie
remarquable avec un sacrifice très beau
conte rochard est une partie très belle
également contre alexis shirov et joël
lautier qui participé l'an dernier qui
n'a dû sa défaite qu'à une gaffe ça
arrive parfois dans une grande fête
juive de mémoire contre contre shirov et
puis de nouveau qui représente la jeune
génération que nous sommes heureux de
saluer christian bauer et laurent
frayssinet et je suis certain que le
spectacle sera à la hauteur de leur
talent vous remercie
merci alors donc là il ya la première
demi finale qui va avoir lieu ça va être
le match
joël lautier qui est numéro 1 français
depuis dix ans contre laurent frayssinet
et pour commenter ce match donc vous
avez des écouteurs qui sont là
disponibles dans la salle il y en a
beaucoup qui les ont pris vous pouvez
les prendre ils sont derrière vous et
également des gens qui suivent sur
internet donc tout ce que vous savez sur
internet ou présents dans la salle ici
eh bien vous entendrez les mêmes
commentaires c'est ceux de nos
commentateurs vedettes que je vous
demande d'applaudir jean-luc chabanon et
stéphane laborde voile alors on va leur
demander de dire un petit mot déjà un
premier une première analyse sur le
match
laurent frayssinet contre joël lautier
donc stéphane qui est producteur de
diagonale va tout de suite me dire un
mot spectacle oui mais laurent
frayssinet moi c'est un petit peu en
favori puisqu'il est de ma région et de
dax moi je suis de bordeaux donc
j'espère que on va avoir droit à un
match retour explosif et on sait que
laurent fascine et un grand attaquant et
je vais lautier aussi donc ça va faire
des étincelles
merci stéphane et de l'autre côté nous
avons le nouveau tout nouveau grand
maître international jean-luc chavanon
qui vient de réaliser sa troisième
normes et qui lui va commenter l'aspect
psychologique et technique c'est donc
notre technicien alors jean-luc un petit
mot sur le match
psychologiquement alors
psychologiquement on va dire que je vais
le tir est un joueur très expérimenté et
laurent frayssinet donc vient tout juste
de rentrer donc on va dire dans le
circuit des tops joueurs donc ça va être
un match assez assez important d'un
point de vue psychologique puisque la a
envie de confirmer donc son statut de
numéro un français et l'autre envie d'un
petit peu de créer la surprise et de
faire l'exploit donc joël lautier le
favori laurent fois signé l'outsider
c'est le match que nous allons voir tout
de suite donc je vous remercie on va
continuer à vous écouter en cabine et
merci alors maintenant donc après donc
notre hôte
après nos commentateurs nous allons
accueillir nos joueurs donc le premier
on en a déjà parlé donc il est jeune il
n'a que 19 ans il a été
vice champion du monde cadet il est
grand maître depuis deux ans déjà il est
5e junior au monde
il est français il vient de dax du sud
ouest il s'agit de laurent frayssinet
que je vous demande d'applaudir alors
laurent peut être un petit mot sur le
match tu te sens en forme
tu vas faire l'exploit aujourd'hui ça
c'est assez dur à dire avant le match
mais bon je me sens en bonne forme et de
toute façon ça va être un match
intéressant donc j'espère que tu auras
du spectacle pour le public c'est quand
même pour le conjoint bon également avec
nous donc pour cette première demi
finale
il s'agit donc du joueur qui est numéro
1 français depuis dix ans qui a
aujourd'hui 28 ans depuis quelques jours
qui vient de terminer 2e du masters
sanguin qui était sélectionnée pour
jouer la coupe du monde à cannes avec
garry kasparov champion du monde junior
en 1988 donc c'est un petit bout de
temps à adelaïde
alors qu'il n'avait que 15 ans c'est
donc un joueur d'exception très très
fort très vite et très jeunes ils
dominent les essais français depuis plus
de dix ans il s'agit du numéro 1 joël
lautier
alors donc je vais le tuer a priori tu
part favori sur le papier pour ce match
contre laurent peut-être une analyse
rapide du match est ce que tu t'es bien
préparé ce que tu as bien dormi est ce
qu il te fait pas trop peur non ça j'ai
très bien dormi effectivement mais bon
c'est jamais facile quand on est supposé
de favori parce que ça peut payer à
grand-chose dans les parties rapides
en plus je sais que l'on est très malin
donc je vais très méfiant bon on verra
on verra tout ça alors je vais vous
demander de vous asseoir tout de suite
donc pour la première partie c'est
laurent fascine et qui aura les blancs
sur un choix donc comme un des deux
joueurs je lautier jours à lui avec les
noirs deux champions une salle en
échiquier
mais il faut encore quelqu'un qui
départage les joueurs en cas de litige
il s'agit de l' arbitre qui est un
arbitre international il s'agit de
thierry parisse donc bonjour thierry
alors peut-être il faut nous rappeler
les règles de ce tournoi c'est à dire la
cadence
bon les enjeux de cette partie comment
ça va se dérouler en cas d'égalité
quelle est la cadence on va faire un
rappel
donc ce sont les parties semi-rapides
chaque joueur dispose de 22 minutes pour
jouer sa partie mais à chaque coup joué
deux secondes seront crédités sur la
pendule donc 22 minutes plus 2 secondes
par coup ont fait ce match en banque en
matches aller retour c'est à dire que je
vais la jouer une fois la clé noir puis
il aura une la même partie contre
laurent mais avec les blancs en cas
d'égalité nous aurons une série enfin de
glisse de départage donc là deux blitz
également une fois avec les noirs mclean
et avec les blancs cinq minutes par
joueur
s'il ya une nouvelle égalité on refait
une série de blitz à nouveau donc deux
fois une fois avec les noirs une fois
avec les blancs et si nous avons
toujours l'égalité
nous aurons un ultime blitz de départage
ou là les blancs auront cinq minutes et
les noirs quatre minutes à la pendule et
obligations pour les blancs de gagner
voilà donc
la règle les règles sont simples donc
maintenant on va tout simplement
éteindre les lumières mettre les
pendules en route et commencer la partie
donc je vais le lotier contre laurent
frayssinet s'est tout de suite voilà en
reprenant maintenant le commentaire avec
jean-luc chavanon une partie qui va
s'annoncer passionnante
voilà les premiers cours ont été joués
de 4 c 5 on rentre tout de suite dans
une sicilienne laurent frayssinet qui
qui est très déterminé puisqu'il a déjà
tombé la veste en début de partie et qui
donc qui commence par une par une par
son coût favoris eux deux quatre et
c'est une sicilienne c'est une si sienne
c'est une position que les deux joueurs
connaissent pas très bien puisqu'ils ont
joué ce type de position il n'ya pas
longtemps à enghien autres mois
d'enghien donc laurent frayssinet qui va
probablement
jouer petit rock ou cavaliers c3 donc à
enghien il avait joué cavalli ces trois
peut-être une surprise pour cette partie
donc cavalier sétois g6 les joueurs
peuvent donc répète alors partie
d'enghien donc là pour l'instant tout et
tout est préparé tout a déjà été jouée
c'est un débat théorique entre les deux
joueurs
et à ce moment là donc laurent
frayssinet donc en pleine réflexion
quelle variante il va sortir pour cette
partie on ne le sait pas leurs racines
et donc qui avait fait quatre points sur
neuf à enghien alors que je vais loti
lui avait fait 2e de ce tournoi donc un
jeu de lautier qui avait fait deuxième
d'un catégorie 17 ce qui est
exceptionnel donc un tournoi avec avec
de très très fort joueur puisqu'il y
avait donc il y avait le vice il ya le
vide
il y avait des nibards eev qui a été
finaliste de la coupe du monde
wilfrid la coupe du monde deux parties
rapides à cannes qu'on avait retransmis
sur canal web et y avait aussi à combien
il y avait aussi venir à copenhague qui
lui a été vice champion du monde il y a
deux ans je crois de mille oeuvres est
exactement dans les 99 pardon donc je
vais le tir en pleine concentration
voilà donc on
on voit que les joueurs donc là pour
l'instant alors sur notre échiquier de
démonstration on peut voir alors que la
laurent fasciné a choisi le coup h3 ils
avaient dit qu'ils joueraient h3 rentrée
ciné ça a été répondu par daems et 7h 3
qui est une qui est à coup donc pas
ordinaire donc c'est un coup à ces
nouveaux donc dans cette position ce
n'est pas le coût habituel puisque on a
l'habitude de jouer petit rock dans
cette position mais je pense que h3
c'était probablement pour préparer aux
4/5 puisque le cavalier m6 n'avait pas
de case mais dam dam des huit c7
contrôler la case aux cinq ce donc ce
n'est plus possible
voilà donc laurent fascine et qui va
peut-être rocqué dans cette position
voilà donc cette sicilienne qui est une
ouverture extrêmement agressive donc je
rappelle que laurent frayssinet a
préféré jouer cette première partie donc
avec les blancs c'est ce qui était
finalement ce qui était le choix donc de
joël lautier était de prendre les noirs
quoi qu'il arrive on joue entre les
parties parce que leur faut signer a
très confiance donc dans les noirs donc
pour la partie revanche laurent
frayssinet donc qui pensent qu'il peut
tenir la position très facilement contre
entre beaucoup de joueurs on rappelle
que ses résultats avec les noirs
actuellement sont nettement meilleures
qu'avec les blancs ont dit il avait dit
qu'il était assez comme ça mais les
noirs c'est pour ça qu'il choisit les
blancs en première par un première main
et alors là a été joué le coup eux 7,5
dont les sept taureaux 1 et cette scène
donc 7,5 finalement la solution pour
éviter la poussée du pur eux et
maintenant donc la position devient plus
un peu plus fermé avec un petit problème
quand même pour les pour les noirs
maintenant si que la casse des cinq
s'ouvre au cavalier blanc
oui il faut vouloir sauter sur cette
case peut-être plus tard elle est
affaiblie cette case et peut-être ça
peut être un thème pour les blancs
d'envahir cette case il va falloir pour
cela déloger le cavalier f6 mais ça peut
être un thème dans la position
et oui donc la russie visait donc des d2
d3 donc pour l'instant je pense que les
blancs vont essayer de terminer leur
développement et est d'obtenir donc
d'obtenir un jeu de pièces assez
optimale avant d'ouvrir la position ce
qui semble très logique on bon pour
l'instant la tour ont finalement
maintenant que la position est ferme et
n'est pas n'est pas à sa place idéale
mais mais bon les blancs sont très très
bien développé de toute façon en
contrepartie les blancs ont réussi à
fait bien la casse des cinq c'est le
point ça va être le point central de
cette position sûrement il est vraiment
peut-être continuer leur développement
par foot g5 menacé de s'échanger contre
le cab et m6 et ensuite en valeur la
casse des 5 avec le cavalier c3
autrement si on fait une petite analyse
technique donc de cette rencontre on
peut dire que cette rencontre est la
rencontre une des rencontres au sommet
donc de pour pour ces demi finales
puisque puisque laurent frayssinet et
joël l'autize sont les deux les deux
joueurs français en forme pour le moment
les résultats donc qu'ils ont
fait chacun dans les équipes dans leurs
équipes respectives c'est à dire je le
dis et joue pour le club de clichy et
laurent faut signer pro club de
montpellier sont excellents donc les
deux joueurs ont fait une très très
bonne saison pour l'instant et donc joël
lautier qui cette année donc depuis
qu'il a entraînée bladimir krainik pour
son match contre garry kasparov est en
excellente forme et quant à laurent
frayssinet donc lui c'est un jeune
joueur mais qui travaillent énormément
les échecs est qui et qui lui aussi est
en très bonne forme devient très bonne
forme le rang précise et surtout il a
bondi au niveau du classement elo
puisqu'il a maintenant je crois 2580 à
peu près points c'est beaucoup quoi ça
commence à le rapprocher de 2006 et donc
ils rentrent dans les 100 meilleurs
joueurs du monde
exactement d'ailleurs je crois qu'elles
sont classement intermédiaire il avait
franchi la barre mythique donc des 2600
mais il est repassé un petit peu en
dessous récemment donc il frôle donc les
2600 il n'en est pas loin
ce qui le place déjà donc au rang de
cinquième junior mondial ce qui ce qui
est vraiment remarquable
mais en face de lui évidemment il ya
aussi l'ancien landes l'ancien champion
du monde juniors donc un autre alors que
peut jouer joël lautier sur cette
position
alors on peut imaginer les coûts
candidat il peut faire le petit rock
mais peut-être sûr pas dire 'ok laurent
frayssinet a prévu de jouer ou g5 pour
s'échanger contre le cavalier f6 et
sauter en fait sur la case des 5 avec
104 lycées 3 oui probablement donc joël
lautier jouer petit rock et et laurent
frayssinet va évidemment essayer de
trouver donc une manière d'exploiter
donc cette case des cinq dont une
méthode pour activer son jeu de pièces
c'est vrai que fou fou c'est un g5 est
une possibilité intéressante non il
préfère ramener donc s'en fout sur ces 4
donc ils préfèrent un et s'en fout sur
la grande sur la diagonale à 2 g 8
voilà la grande diagonale à 2 g 8 c'est
vrai que le fou en bessin qui n'exerçait
plus une pression assez illusoire donc
entre deux soirées diagonale à 4,8 dont
il recycle son fou sur une meilleure des
gonades c'est très logique
17 des 6-17 des six peut-être joué
lautier veut développer sont fous ces
huit sur la case e6 peut-être pour
contrôler un peu plus la case des 5
voilà donc maintenant laurent fascine et
qui va probablement bondir sur cette
case centrale une position pour
l'instant donc très très solide de la
part des noirs est toujours se trouve
sur la casse des cinq c'est le seul le
seul handicap de cette position avec les
noirs est-ce que je hais ce que laurent
fasciné va réussir à s'en emparer
c'est tout l'enjeu de cette position
tout l'enjeu de ce début de partie
voilà donc pour cette partie rapide une
cadence une cadence qui qui va laisser
qui va laisser du temps aux joueurs
puisque les joueurs disposent de 25
minutes plus 2 secondes par coup c'est à
peu près à peu près comme au championnat
de
au championnat du monde deux parties
rapides ou là il disposait de 25 minutes
et avait un rajout de temps après le 50e
coup c'est donc une cadence qui leur
permet donc de de ne pas être comment
dire en partie rapide
quelquefois il ya des miettes des chaos
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya il n'y a pas de
rajout de temps et là ils ont un rajout
ton donc ils peuvent terminer la partie
tranquillement
donc je vais lautier toujours très
concentrée stefan wey toujours très
concentrée ça c'est à laurent a joué
cavalier sur la case des deux d'un coup
surprenant pas si surprenant que ça
puisque le cavalier des deux va donc
être recyclés probablement sur la case
f1 puis e3 voilà le plan voilà donc le
cavalier qui va qui va rebondir sur les
cases centrale une manoeuvre très connue
donc dans ce type de position
il va donc profiter finalement du fait
que les sept tours ne soit pas placée
sur la colonne eve pour placer son
cavalier et après peut-être qui
replacera la tour 20 en f1 pour ouvrir
le jeu par f2f 4 voilà donc des
possibilités
effectivement je veux loti à jouer le
couffo 6 pour contrôler une fois de plus
la case des cinq noter que si les blancs
échangeant aussi ça est de me lenouar
consolider leur centre oui donc échanger
aussi ce ne serait pas davantage des
blancs puisque le pion f7 reviendrait
sur la case e6 contrôlerait la case
centrale des 5 et la colonne f serait
ouverte ce qui ce qui donc serait plutôt
l avantage des noirs
donc cavalier des deux f1 et loire une
loi qui rentre en cabine qui va donc
nous donner ses impressions donc sur sur
cette position qui pour l'instant donc
les qu'un début oui effectivement c'est
le début de la partie c'est clair bon
maintenant laurent frayssinet a dit
qu'il avait préparé qu'il allait jouer h
3o cinquième coup il l'avait dit hier il
avait pris un pari là dessus
effectivement on remarque qu'il a joués
h 3o cinquième coup donc laurent
frayssinet qui est très très sport
puisque ils annoncent les coups qu'il va
jouer contre le numéro un français joël
lautier
il est assez fun laurent frayssinet donc
là la position objectivement bon semble
semble comment dire bon équilibre et
encore jean luc r je pense que tout est
à faire
pour l'instant donc les deux joueurs ont
développé leur pièce normalement donc il
n'y a rien de il n'y a rien de spécial
il n'y a pas d'erreur qui a été commise
pour l'instant c'est un jeu très
classique jeu très classique parties
rapides donc je vais le lotier gianotti
les super concentré il vient de jouer h
7 h 6 alors que le renvoi sine die du
jury qui avait des f-16 on voit le plan
de laurent frayssinet qui donc de jouer
le cavalier enfin sur la case de 3
ensuite avec son duo de cavaliers jean
luc et d'aït va envahir la caisse des 5
alors est-ce que ce choix d'ouverture a
été bien fait contre joël lautier
ah bah ça joue vite d'ailleurs sa jolie
et cavaliers de trois cavaliers e set
voilà donc cavalier e set pour l'instant
c'est une lutte pour les quatre
centrales pour la casse des cinq plus
particulièrement non et que je vais
lautier donc qui qui ne veut pas qu'une
pièce s'installe sur la cause des saints
qui préféreraient voir un pion sur cette
case
on le comprend logiquement puisque si
c'est un cavalier lecavalier dominerait
énormément de cases et si c'est un fou
le fou donc
ce serait donc sur cette diagonale à 2
g8 il serait il serait le seul
dominerait complètement donc là c'est la
lutte pour la case centrale et en même
temps donc joël lautier qui a joué h 7 h
6 va préparer probablement la manoeuvre
3g 8 h 7 pour défendre un petit peu son
rock et plus tard éventuellement essayer
de pousser le pion f pour passer à la
contre offensive mais beaucoup plus tard
pour l'instant ce n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour
effectivement donc toulon joue de cette
position jean luc
c'est la fameuse case des cinq la
fameuse case des cinq dons qui est ici
au centre de l'échiquier les noirs
contrôler au maximum les blancs aussi et
maintenant on se demande jean luc
quelles peuvent être les prochains coups
de laurent frayssinet pour accroître la
pression donc le prochain coup peut-être
serait d'installer quand même malgré
tout un cavalier sur sur cette fameuse
case centrale alors que là nous voyons
laurent frayssinet donc là on parle pour
les internautes puisque il ya laurent
frayssinet à l'image
en revanche si vous êtes dans la salle
et bien vous le voyez laurent frayssinet
très concentré en train de réfléchir
il est en train de se demander comment
il va faire à noter qu'il a l'air très
calme le rang jean-luc puisqu'ils ne
bouge pas alors qu'à son habitude il est
un peu tendue comme un ressort
oui exactement donc laurent frayssinet
qui est qui qui n'est pas trop stressé
qui pour l'instant donc gère bien cette
partie
bon c'est vrai que c'est une partie de
50 minutes donc ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas c'est la première de la journée donc
le pour l'instant ce n'est qu'un début
il va peut-être jouer tour efforts dans
cette position peut-être qui va essayer
de replacer cette tour le 1 sur la
colonne f pour éventuellement essayer
d'ouvrir par f2f 4 c'est une possibilité
dont il joue food et de donc laurent
fascine et qui patiemment termine son
développement alors que je le lotier a
les idées très claires puisque lui il
sait ce qu'il fait joël il réfléchit
très peu dans ce début de partie
on va peut-être faire un bilan pendule 1
alors qu'il reste
si on ne fait pas d'erreur 17 minutes
ajoie lautier et il n'en reste que 14 à
laurent frayssinet et oui donc jeanne
lethier qui est très expérimenté il faut
rappeler que je vais lautier donc
à jouer la coupe du monde deux parties
rapides à cannes il y à il ya deux mois
donc il a un entraînement incroyable
puisque il avait échoué donc et de très
peu la qualification pour les quarts de
finale et donc il est il est l'homme
l'homme fort dans cette dans ce type de
de cadence 14e coup
vingt neuf dames 2 il veut contre
attaquer sur le pion de saint laurent
frayssinet si les noirs jouent des 5
il vient après un échange sur la case
des cinq par le pion heureux la dame
apeurée après sur le pion e5 protégé par
la tour
c'est une des idées mais pas forcément
la principale je pense que l'idée de
dameuses peut-être c'est tout simplement
de lille les tours c'est un coup laurent
frayssinet veut pas trop se prendre la
tête
il veut pas perdre de temps à réfléchir
et il veut simplement de lier les tours
puisqu'on voit que maintenant les tours
se contrôlent mutuellement
donc c'est un coup de dé veloppement je
pense qu'on peut formuler sa wii un
choix psychologique intéressant
puisqu'on on a l'impression quand même
que
le placement des pièces de joël lautier
et extrêmement agressif
donc la meilleure solution finalement
face à une telle configuration et de
placer ses pièces pour pour un éventuel
contre donc une stratégie curieuse avec
les blancs mais quand même très logique
laurent frayssinet j'aurai donc en
contre alors on note dans cette position
que les deux fous sont en prise
simultanée c'est à dire que chacun des
fous peut prendre l'autre ce qui
engendrerait donc à ce moment là s'il
est noir prenaient un affaiblissement de
la structure de ce sont des blancs
puisqu'il devrait reprendre avec
l'option des et 6 et les blancs qui
prennent le fou noir il y à comprendre
mais dans les deux cas en fait les pions
doublé serait un renforcement structure
jean luc oui exactement donc il ne faut
absolument pas prendre les fous ne
peuvent pas se prendre donc c'est très
curieuse c'est ce qu'on appelle un
véritable bras de fer donc les deux fous
se regarde droit dans les yeux et ne
peuvent pas s'échanger il serait en
droit dans les yeux alors c'est possible
en tout cas joel gauthier laurent
fasciné eux ne se regarde pas il regarde
la position et joël là on sent qu'ils
ont un coût responsables et n'ont
apparemment un petit coup un petit coup
de gueule lautier d'un de ses 7 ans et 8
qu'est ce que c'est que ça alors
peut-être jean-luc une analyse
psychologique de ce coup qui part de
manière rationnelle aura du mal à être
expliquée oui donc 26 7 6 8
je le dis donc ne veut pas toucher sa
structure de pions il ne veut pas jouer
deux coups responsable c'est ça c'est
une évidence alors un plan peut-être
pour les noirs de ses positions c'est de
taper sur la case h3 et peut-être de
jouer car il ya six ans h5 suivi de
cavaliers en f4 et f5 celui de kelly
avec un oui une autre explication adams
et 8 serait tout simplement de préparer
la prise du fou en russie ce par l'adam
ce qui permettrait toujours de contrôler
la case des 5 et qu'il garderait la
possibilité vraiment d'obtenir un gros
centre par fcf 5 donc le pion qui
resteraient sur f77 une autre
possibilité assez logique
alors que l'on vous faut c'est bien de
jouer à 2 à 4 1 à 2 à 4 curieux on sent
que laurent n'a pas vraiment les idées
claires il fait et il n'a pas vraiment
l'air de faire de plan
je sais pas j'ai l'impression quand même
à deux à quatre c'est un début
d'offensive allait l'allèle dame donc
laurent frayssinet qui va plus tard
jouer b2b 4 et qui commence pour qu'ils
commencent donc à lens est donc une
offensive de pions pour affaiblir cette
structure noir qui pour l'instant est
est assez indestructible c'est possible
c'est possible laurent frayssinet très
concentré et je vais le voter
il vient de jouer des six des 5 alors ça
ça c'est un coup c'est un coût qui en
jette c'est le coup libérateur alors là
ça ça c'est ça va très vite puis on
prend des cinq cavaliers f prendrait 5
tous les joueurs jouent à tempo pour
l'instant il peut y avoir un échange
généralisé et une position égale qui a
l'air de ressortir de sa jean-luc vous
voyez donc un échange généralisé une
position inial une position peut-être
avec un petit avantage blanc puisque
leur structure donc serait serait plus
saines et les pions sur les pions noirs
se retrouverait en 5 séances et 5 donc
sur la case du fou g7
ce qui serait peut-être un avantage on
va dire un avantage microscopie plus que
les pièces noires sont quand même très
bien développé alors voilà dont il a
joué un échange du cavalier 3 sur la
cause des saints qui suivit de cavaliers
prend voilà donc toutes les pièces
s'échange toutes les pièces échanges
tout reprend et maintenant fous ces 3
voilà donc fusé 3 laurent frayssinet qui
place son fou face aux pions noirs eux 5
voilà ce fou mais tel un qui table sur
le pion aux cinq qui a aidé par la dame
et la tour et ses protégés pour
l'instant par la tour et le foulée 7
voilà donc laurent frayssinet qui qui va
peut-être plus tard place et sa dame sur
la case centrale
le khat est dans cette position donc un
avantage vraiment microscopique pour les
blancs mais une position très très
solide donc le rang fascine et qui
utilise qui joue une partie très
technique
donc pour cette pour ce premier match
et on espère que on espère que la partie
va quand même un petit peu s'animer
parce que pour l'instant c'est un
échange généralisé ce n'est pas très ce
n'est pas très excitant pour l'instant
mais c'est quand même du jeu du jeu de
très très précis pour l'instant cette
partie s'achemine vers l'égalité donc
dams et 8,6 alors qu'autant reste
moi je vois pas bien et là joël qui
place la dame qui rapproche saddam donc
du centre c'est très logique
il anticipe peut-être le ku'damm e2 e4
pour préparer peut-être un échange de
drame donc laurent qui à son habitude va
probablement essayer de rechercher une
finale très technique car curieusement
donc laurent
malgré son jeune âge a quand même une
technique assez incroyable donc dame si
ça a été jouée suivi de dames 4 du coup
logique
pour l'instant la pression est du côté
blanc qui pilonne soutien aux cinq ans
peut-être laurent veut doubler les tours
jetons aux deux suivis de tours alain
exactement exactement ça pour vous voyez
faire partie des possibilités donc
doubler les tours sur la colonne eux et
éventuellement donc peut-être préparé
dans certains cas donc préparé des
manoeuvres donc sur ce pion au sein qui
est peut-être ouvrir plus tard on sais
pas en tout cas il se garde plein de
possibilités et et on voit pas comment
donc joël va prendre l'initiative dans
sa cousine
pour ses 80 ours et 8 jo elle qui joue
un coup très très malin puisque la tour
la tour des cinq a peut-être envie de
quitter la tour des 5 va peut être
quitter cette case et auquel cas si les
dames s'échangent la tour c 8 pourrait
prendre la dame en c6 et venir sur la
sixième rang j'ai peut-être les noirs
prépare aussi la pousser ces cas ces
cinq c4 pour simplifier ses cinq c4 qui
pourrait simplifier la position oui
exactement qui pourrait même contrer la
position mais là je pense que leur ont
valu au b2 b3 voilà c'est ce qu'il fait
donc il faut interdire ce pion il faut
interdire la poussée du plan c c'est
très logique
à noter que c'est bien joué de la part
des blancs puisque tous les pions blancs
son contrôle les cases blanches voyez
son show cases blanches qui contrôle les
cases blanches alors que le fouillis
contrôler les cases noires oui donc leur
ont pour l'instant qui qui augmente son
avantage positionnelle puisque le fou
ces trois donc un fou de cases noires
donc au final serait supérieur aux fous
g7 puisque puisqu'il attaquerez des
pions les pions au 5 et les pions c5
pour l'instant alors que le fou adverse
les défendre et tout simplement oui il
n'y aurait pas de papa de points en
attaque pour les cases noires du fou g7
se fout g7 pour l'instant uniquement
défensif alors que laurent fait signer
lui tape sur le pion au no 5 voilà donc
bessette b6 donc encore
encore un coup logique je vais essayer
de consolider sa structure de pions mais
il rajoute un pion sur la couleur de 2
200 fou donc bon pour l'instant un petit
avantage blanc petit avantage blanc très
technique donc un choix psychologique
intéressant puisque laurent frayssinet
donc qui joue une position extrêmement
technique à son adversaire qui qu'il ya
une grande erreur la journée soro ii il
a joué tour de laurent frayssinet il
veut doubler les tours et augmenté la
pression sur le pion aux 5
voilà donc on peut peut-être aussi
envisagé donc après après la double et
des tours sur la colonne ne peut être
que la dame de 4 va quitter cette case
quand même parce que la dame devant les
devants les tours c'est pas trés c'est
pas très bien pour prendre le pion aux
cinq mois elle pourrait venir notamment
sur la case c4 peut-être cette dame
vous serez bien placé les continuerai il
faudrait une pression peut-être un petit
peu sur le plan f 7 travers la tour et
elle pour eux également pour dire sur la
casa 6 à l'oreille d'autres possibilités
voilà donc ce serait possible et en même
temps donc lors on peut se permettre
dans cette position de jouer de gagner
et de récupérer du temps puisque les
difficultés sont sont noirs donc un
petit avantage blanc très désagréable
pour l'instant un techno là pour
l'instant lorrains se régale sur les
cases blanches
il a pris vraiment bien le contrôle sur
casse blanche et son fou contrôle bien
les cases noires donc alors qu'il reste
10 minutes pour les blancs et 11 minutes
pour les noirs donc ça se tient vraiment
à la pendule
c'est très très peu clair c'est très peu
claires mais quand même un petit plus
pour oloron
donc qu'est ce que tu en penses
stéphane oui un petit plus pour laurent
est tout à fait qui contrôle bien la
fois les cases blanches les cases noires
maintenant il n'ya qu'une seule
faiblesse dans le camp north le pion aux
scènes qu'on sait que pour gagner une
partie il faut en créer deux en général
il faut au moins de faiblesses
donc quel autre faiblesse pour être
créée par laurent peut-être un coup
qu'on a quatre à cinq est envisageable
voilà donc on remarque pour l'instant
les rois n'ont pas bougé je suis ce
n'est pas encore la finale aussi donc
les rois qui reste bien à l'abri mais je
pense que d'ici quelques coups peut-être
qu'un des deux qu'on va essayer de
d'échanger les dames
je pense que c'est plutôt les noirs dans
cette position qui ont intérêt à
échanger les dames parce que parce que
le roi noir pourrait monter plus
facilement au centre puisque le pion f
une fois qu'il serait poussé laurent
montrer directement sur f7 et tout ce
serait plus facile pour le roi noir de
monter au centre et cette dame blanche
quand même est très bien placé au centre
donc vous donner pour l'instant on peut
pas reculer la tour si l'on perdrait le
pion aux cinq exactement mais lorsqu'on
a vu joël jouer tout à leur tour ces 8
suivi de b6 on a compris que c'était
pour défendre cette dame c'est parce
qu'il veut échanger des dames
voilà donc on on connaît ses intentions
et il va essayer de faire un plan pour
pour faciliter cet échange donc joël qui
joue à six un coup logique donc je elle
qui s'apprête à qui voudrait échanger un
petit peu ses pions tu voudrais jouer b6
b5 et changer les pions à est peut-être
plus tard jouer ces cinq c4 donc pour
pour échanger un maximum de pions et
et rendre la position complètement égal
alors sans réel avantage quand même pour
les biens de créer un pion passé il ya
une majorité elle dames quatre pions
contre 3 ça pourrait créer un pion passé
pour les blancs si lille noir venait à
changer tous ses pions et peut-être ça
pour créer un déséquilibre mais je
voulais elle commence à mettre ses pions
sur les cases blanches
oui donc créer un puits en passer oui
mais de toute façon ceux qui ont passé
sera très difficile a avancé puisque les
pièces les tours donc seraient placés
sur les lignes ouvertes immédiatement
pour le contrer laurent frayssinet va
peut-être gardé sa tour en a un
puisque si joël j'oublais 5 la tour 1
pourrait tout simplement jouer sur la
colonne a et il rêvait 6v 5n échanges
dans des scènes qu on échange sur cette
case ici le pion pour s'échanger et la
tour pourrait bondir par exemple sur las
casas est lourd une grande une grande
action notamment sur le pion avec 7
voilà donc laurent qui joue dame f3
évidemment il n'a pas l'intention donc
de toucher cette tour a tout de suite
il préfère manoeuvrer un petit peu il
sent comme difficile de devoir de voir
sa stratégie donc pour l'instant puisque
il ne crée pas de deux nouveaux de
nouveaux contacts avec de nouveaux
points d'action sur le sur l'échiquier
donc pour l'instant
c'est vrai que la position s'équilibrent
un petit peu après ce coup à 7 à 6 un
coup très précis de la part de joël je
suppose et quand même que lui blanc à
doubler leur tour ce qui obligerait la
les noirs à défendre notamment placé la
tour s'est vite peut-être sur la case de
oui donc évidemment on joint dame e cat
f3 joue elle se réserve la possibilité
de laurent se réserve se réserver la
possibilité de jouer tour a eu un
ça y est joël donc veut échanger les
dames donc il a joué tour des six ans
mais on dirait que ça perd le pion aux
cinq mois il doit y avoir d une pointe y
avoir une pointe si les dames
s'échangent et bien tout simplement
reprendre de la tour et si les blancs
prennent le pion aux 5 et bien on fait
un clouage c'est à dire que la tour c 8
viendrait sur la case 8 et le fou ne
peut plus bouger sous peine de perdre la
tour aux deux oui exactement donc le
pion aux 5 n'est pas en prise c'est un
piège donc joël qui qui va réussir à
échanger ces dames et après la position
va être presque presque égal est ce
qu'on peut vous avez parlé de la
faiblesse du pillon 5 c'est aussi un
pion central qui peut se révéler fort
quand même
oui il peut s'en passer il peut ce qui
peut pousser les mêlées fort et faible
quand même ce pion dans tout à fait oui
appuyé fort et faible en fin de toute
façon donc dans cette position aucune
pièce bourrée pourrait pourrait aider
donc les noirs l'ailé nord n'ont
vraiment aucune chance de à ce moment là
de la partie les noirs joue en défense
ils tiennent tout simplement à tenir la
position et on va voir ce que peuvent
trouver les blancs ce n'est pas évident
puisque le roi comme j'ai expliqué tout
à l'heure le roi blanc ne peut pas trop
se placer vers le centre c'est le gros
problème des blancs dans cette position
donc après tour allemand les noirs
disposerait peut-être dans l'état mans
était censé aidé à moins qu'ils aient
changé
voilà alors là c'est à dire que là il
faut faire attention le pion aux 5 étant
prises lorsque les blancs peuvent le
prendre
fou prend 1,5 à l'heure de gagner un
pion mais il y aurait
pour ces six ans le 6 et le fousseret
cloud et puisque la tour 2 serait
derrière sans défense ça perdrait une
pièce perdre et la qualité ont gardé la
qualité c'est à dire une tour contre un
fou donc c'est un piège que temps joël
lautier vas-y je te laisse le pion
emprise on s'achemine vers la nul c nul
voilà donc joël qui a bien réussi sa
stratégie d'échanger les dames au bon
moment et de tenir la position donc
laurent qui n'a pas réussi la première
partie nulle alors que les deux joueurs
on voit discuter un peu de la partie
le micro donc petit problème technique
je répète la partie a été déclarée nulle
d'un commun accord
voilà donc bon de jouer en fait nul donc
une petite remarque pour les volumes des
casques pour la prochaine partie il
faudra les baisser un petit peu parce
que les joueurs entendent les
commentaires donc je dis pas que ça les
aide mais en tout cas ça les gêne alors
là ce qui va se passer c'est qu'on va
faire une petite pause d'une dizaine de
minutes
donc on va vous inviter à éventuellement
aller à côté je peux souffler excusez
moi j'étais surpris par cette part cette
fin rapide
donc je vous invite à aller à côté ou
éventuellement même à rester là les
joueurs se reposent dix minutes vous
enchaînez avec la revanche tout de suite
voilà donc et bien à tout de suite
ce
tu es lautié
la première partie a été nul donc deux
joueurs vont se reposer pendant dix
minutes avant que l'on puisse assister à
la revanche
oui donc les deux joueurs qui ont qu'ils
n'ont pas besoin de plus de 10 minutes
parce que cette partie finalement était
une partie assez classique
sans surprise les joueurs donc ce sont
c'était une sorte de round d'observation
les deux joueurs ont se sont testés un
petit peu laurent frayssinet donc a
voulu jouer une position très technique
pour dire voilà on va voir si si tu sais
tenir une position évidemment joël avec
toute son expérience a tenu assez
facilement cette position est maintenant
donc on va voir si la stratégie de
laurent va fonctionner c'est à dire
jouer la partie revanche avec les noirs
donc jouer une position extrêmement
solide je jouais encore également une
position extrêmement solide face à un
joueur qui va être là pour pour
l'attaqué tout simplement
voilà donc
eloire relange sur scène qui nous fait
signe de continuer évidemment si vous
nous rejoignez sur internet
on vous rappelle que cette première
partie entre laurent frayssinet jouer
lautier laurent fait signer avec les
blancs s'est terminée par la partie
nulle parti finalement pas du tout
explosive on peut dire ça a été très
technique mais les noms ont réussi à
égaliser sans trop de problèmes et oui
donc deux stars médiatiques se sont
rencontrés puisque donc
les deux les deux les deux espoirs donc
des échecs français laurent frayssinet
et je vais lautier viennent de se
rencontrer mais ça n'a pas été un choc
extraordinaire mais bon c'est vrai que à
ce niveau les parties sont souvent très
techniques comme on peut le constater
d'ailleurs kasparov et krainik ont
également joué des parties qui se sont
terminées assez rapidement par là nul
sans éclat
c'est le cas est bon la revanche
probablement va être beaucoup plus
tendue puisque les joueurs n'ont qu'un
objectif c'est gagné oui et ça comme
cannes parties nulles de toute façon on
aura droit à des bisses de départage
donc tôt ou tard on va avoir le feu sur
l'échiquier on va un petit peu rappelé
la carrière des joueurs donc stéphane
est ce que tu donc tu vas nous parler un
petit peu de jouer de lautier ouais je
vais le lotier qui a été champion du
monde juniors le plus jeune de
l'histoire en 88 adélaïde
il avait 15 ans il avait obtenu son
titre de grand maître d'ailleurs à cette
occasion puisque quand on rencontre le
canton remporte le titre mondial junior
on devient en général grands maîtres
dans la foulée et depuis il a notamment
pu marquer que c'est un des rares
joueurs au monde être positifs contre
kasparov
il mène 2 à 1 sur un total d' je sais
plus de dix partis je crois exactement
joël lautier qui est positif contre
garry kasparov sait-on que le ça était
le joueur qui a travaillé avec vladimir
kramnik pour son match brenda games donc
pour son match de championnat du monde
il ya quelques mois et qui a permis à
vladimir donc par par sa préparation
qui a permis à vladimir de gagner ce
match je vais le luthier donc qui a
quand même une petite particularité donc
dans sa carrière c'est qu'il n'a jamais
été champion de france il n'a jamais
réussi à obtenir le titre de champion de
france et probablement donc ce cette
rencontre fait partie des rencontres qui
qui est qu'ils sont très très importante
avant le choc qu'il y aura cet été donc
entre les deux joueurs donc probablement
un match avant avant d'autres matchs les
joueurs dont qui luttent pour cette
première place il faut rappeler que la
situation donc dans les échecs français
a complètement évolué puisqu'il ya
quelques années je vais lautier était de
loin le seul numéro un français est
maintenant ce n'est plus le cas stéphane
oui c'est plus le cas puisque numéro un
il ya un numéro un sur la liste france
qui veut ladislav quatre chefs
oui exactement mais il ya aussi donc
beaucoup de beaucoup d'opposition à joël
lautier puisqu'il y a etienne bacrot way
qui est qui a été deux fois champion de
france et qui étiez donc le plus le
jeune talent français il ya laurent
frayssinet qui également à une carrière
phénoménale puisqu'il a été deux fois
vice champion du monde dans des
catégories jeunes et il ya aussi dont
christian bauer qui va jouer la deuxième
demi-finale donc contre boris spassky en
fin d'après midi
christian bauer qui est numéro 2
français à égalité avec joël bats avec
etienne bacrot c'était d'ailleurs la
surprise du dernier classement avec plus
de 2600 christian bauer qui continue sa
progression mine de rien exactement donc
une surprise pas vraiment puisque en 96
il avait été champion de france devant
des joueurs qui sont aux alentours de
2600 et qui ont de 1600 com
le joueur dorfman donc le joueur cannois
enfin du sud de la france et est donc
christian bauer qui également à dépasser
cette barre mythique des 2600 pour la
première fois et qui tient bien à
conserver donc ce classement oui qui
était bien le conserver même l'augmenter
kristin bauer qui continue son bonhomme
de chemin qui est passé professionnel
maintenant il ya deux ans et qui sans
faire beaucoup de bruit finalement
progresse à un marché mondial il doit
maintenant être dans les soixante
soixante dix meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
voilà et pour ce grand prix du sénat
nous avons donc au également un invité
exceptionnel c'est le champion du monde
boris spassky alors c'est parce qu'
évidemment c'est la légende c'est le
match le plus médiatisé de l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs
peut-être avec les matches kasparov et
karpov c'est le match fischer spassky
qu'elle ait eu lieu à 72 qui a permis à
ce passe passe qui de ce fait
reconnaître même s'il a perdu ce match
on peut dire que les noms des deux
joueurs sont liés fischer espace qui
exactement un match qui a eu lieu à
reykjavik en 1972 et il faut savoir donc
que à l'issue de ce match donc bobby
fischer a obtenu le titre de championne
du monde
et pourtant ces deux joueurs sont restés
en très bons termes après puisqu'ils ont
joué un match revanche vingt ans plus
tard et oui c'est vie stéphane
exactement 92 matchs qui avait fait la
une de libération notamment notamment
avec le titre il revient le retour de
bobby fischer vingt ans après un match
qui avait été d'ailleurs de très bonne
qualité
un match qui avait été de très bonne
qualité boris en garde d'excellents
souvenirs il a perdu le match
évidemment mais
mais c'était quand même un moment très
fort dans l'histoire des échecs et boris
spassky qui a obtenu la nationalité
française donc qui est qui a quitté la
russie donc l'ex urss en 77 je crois
ouais et qui donc s'est installé en
france à l'époque donc à l'époque où
sévissent et anatoli karpov donc sur la
scène internationale est qui et qui donc
depuis donc jouent à jouer quelques
quelques fois pour l'équipe de france
nous a rendus plusieurs services donc il
a même joué à choper la france je m'en
souviens parce que je le joue et oui en
91 à montpellier est donc actuellement
au sa carrière c'est un petit peu
arrêter plus ou moins puisqu'il continue
à jouer régulièrement des des tournois
donc des tournois des mémorial des
mémorial notamment récemment il a joué
le temps suisse qui célébrait
l'anniversaire de victor coronary
exactement donc il a joué le ton en
suisse où il a bien figuré
il a il est revenu en forme il nous a
dit donc qu'il ya lors de la conférence
de presse qu'il avait d'ailleurs qu'il
avait d'ailleurs joué quelques parties
donc très intéressante qui des partis
qui mérite d'être regardée à de plus
près oui tout à fait c'est parce qu'ils
qu'il reste un joueur à battre un joueur
d'un excellent niveau
mais on en n'est pas là champion du
monde par hasard et quand on est content
d'arrêter une fois champion du monde
bon on va rappeler aussi par exemple
le casse miss love smith love qui a été
championne du monde en 58 et qui en 83
je crois avait fini en finale des
candidats contre kasparov donc plus de
vingt ans après donc un petit avis aux
spectateurs de cette salle médicis et
aux téléspectateurs de canal web
boris spassky sous ses allures
grisonnante est tout de même très très
redoutable
ah oui très redoutable c'est clair il
faut pas se rencontrer se passe qui sans
être préparé et affûté
c'est un vieux lion mais il rugit encore
exactement d'ailleurs l'année dernière
il s'était qualifié pour la finale de ce
grand prix du sénat en battant donc en
demi-finale donc le lot le grand maître
roanne et donc arnaud hauchard ouais il
l'avait battu dans un match
dans un match très très excitant puisque
les joueurs avaient joué des parties de
départage et boris spassky s'était
imposé en blitz je crois oui et à
l'issue de ces départager ce match avait
tenu en laye en haleine tout le public
et toutes les cabines des commentaires
je construis la vie droit car les
parties nulles tout le temps n'est parti
nul c'est ça se joue et il n'arrivait
pas à passer les joueurs est d'ailleurs
le bis de le buste de départager s'est
terminée par la nul mais il fallait que
les blancs gagne il avait cinq minutes
contre 4 pour les noirs oui ce match de
départage qui était qui nous a tous
tenus en haleine et qui était vraiment
le le le plus beau spectacle que nous
ayons eu l'année dernière je crois oui
avec les parties de shirov quand même
avec les parties de shirov est également
met donc un boris donc qui qui avait
sacrifié qui avait donc jouer des
parties très très
très très
et très étincelante de très belles
parties donc avec avec un très joli
sacrifice de pièces dont avec les blancs
boris parce qu'il sera peut-être très
redoutable et battante et donc de
de lancer une attaque sur son adversaire
comme il le dit donc les parties rapides
c'est sa spécialité puisqu'il peut jouer
avec la main c'est à dire qu'il n'est
pas obligé de réfléchir c'est vrai qu'à
son âge ce n'est pas facile de tenir
d'être concentré et de tenir le stress
d'une partie de compétition de haut
niveau pendant cinq heures alors que
pendant une petite demi-heure ou ou 50
minutes maximum c'est beaucoup plus
facile mais c'est beaucoup plus facile
et surtout dans quelques instants
donc prendre la première partie entre
donc je vais lautier laurent frayssinet
a été nul donc petit avantage pour joe 2
lotis puisqu'ils avaient les pièces
noires c'est plutôt un bon résultat
maintenant avec les pièces blanches il
va bien entendu essayer de gagner cette
partie puisque s'ils gagnent c'est tout
de suite la victoire du match sur le
score de 1-1 et demi 1/2
s'il perd donc c'est laurent frayssinet
qui se qualifie et s'ils font nulle et
bien il y aura des blitz se départagent
qui suivront donc après une petite pause
de 10 minutes encore donc là bas tout
simplement nous allons rappeler les
joueurs sur le plateau donc je vous
demande de faire très attention avec vos
casques parce qu apparemment ça j'aime
beaucoup les joueurs qu'ils entendent
par exemple oui laurent frayssinet va
doubler ses tours sur la colonne eux est
là c'est assez gênant effectivement
puisque surtout s'il le fait ou
d'ailleurs même s'il le fait pas donc
voilà donc on va les rappeler donc
faites attention avec les casques si
jamais vous entendez qui est un peu trop
de bruit et bien je vous demande
vraiment de les baisser puisque sa
chaîne les joueurs donc on va rappeler
laurent frayssinet et joël lautier pour
la deuxième partie
donc je laisse la parole à monsieur
arbitres pour lancer cette deuxième
manche vient donc on va démarrer je vous
rappelle également de mettre le volume
de vos casques au minimum s'il vous
plaît merci tous demandent le plus grand
silence je veux lancer les pendules
voilà il a démarré je vais lautier par
le coût des deux des quatre suivi par
des cinq de leurs entrées signer ces
quatre essais 6 une variante voilà donc
c'est parti pour cette revanche pour
cette deuxième partie donc de ce match
entre joël lautier et laurent frayssinet
alors laurent frayssinet avec les noirs
va jouer la défense l'avs
c'est sa spécialité et il a il est
extrêmement confiant dans son jeu solide
donc là les joueurs jouent une position
extrêmement connue puisque llc joué
l'année dernière à à cannes entre
etienne bacrot et anatoli karpov dans
leur match et voilà exactement la même
partie donc joël qui a préparé donc une
position un petit peu inhabituel donc
enfin une position que lors on n'a pas
beaucoup beaucoup joué mais mais qui est
tout de même extrêmement solide
voilà donc deux hommes b3 et j'aime v3
la dame fait pression sur le plan b 7
exactement et aussi sur le plan des 5
avec l'option c4
donc voilà donc dans deux des trois donc
m lecavalier à jacques tati qui est là
pour prendre la paire de fou mais lors
on attend un petit peu avant de avant de
prendre ce fonds g6 il attendait un
petit peu puisque la colonne h s'ouvrait
immédiatement et maintenant donc on va
voir ce que fait jouable sur ce coup
dame b 6 il peut jouer une finale par c4
c5
c'est une possibilité il peut proposer
de proposer une finale mais je pense que
lors on refuserait dans ce cas de figure
puisque après dame b6 prend b3 la
colonna se retrouverait tout simplement
ouverte et la torah exercerait une
pression désagréable sur la colonne a en
tout cas c'est une position extrêmement
connue que les joueurs jouent
actuellement f2 f3 il a joué je vais le
lotier donc les les joueurs qui jouent
qui joue une position très classique la
défense smith la défense qui est joué
par les meilleurs joueurs au monde
actuellement qui est le plus joué en
compétition donc ça va être ça peut être
technique mais il reste encore beaucoup
de pièces je pense que ça va être une
partie très très très compliqué
exactement donc là joël loti vient de
prendre le fongecif et on suppose que
joël va peut-être jouer maintenant food
et deux pour garder un maximum de
possibilités d'en garder la possibilité
de faire le grand roque et voilà
exactement l'eau qui fait fou des deux
et pour terminer son développement alors
la question qu'on se pose c'est l'euro
fasciné va-t-il continuer son
développement par cavalier b17 ou
va-t-en t-il va-t-il tenter quelque
chose de plus
non il se développe de manière
extrêmement classique
aucune surprise pour l'instant on
constate que les deux joueurs contrôlent
très très bien les cases centrale avec
avec un duo d 4d cas de c4 a légèrement
supérieure pour les blancs
mais bon rien et rien n'est clair pour
l'instant puisque la paire de cavaliers
dans cette position est utile puisque
pour l'instant la paire de foot blanche
n'est pas n'est pas très forte les fous
étant fermé pour l'instant voilà grand
roque et on peut dire que l'an passé
lorsque karpov et bacrot avait joué sept
cette position savez la position noir
avaient montré je crois une grande
grande grande solidité alors on a
l'impression que les les blancs sont
bien ils ont une belle position mais
c'est loin d'être facile pour passer un
cap un style jean luc oui c'est loin
d'être facile pour passer on constate
que la tourache 8 déjà est extrêmement
bien placé puisque elle elle domine donc
elle rayonne donc sur 7 sur cette
colonne ouverte le elle tape le pion h 2
ce qui explique la raison ce qui
explique le coût grand roque
évidemment on va pas placés sont rangés
un houleux les droits seraient
légèrement affaibli plus plus tard les
noirs peuvent également exercer une
pression désagréable sur la diagonale b
8 h 2 ce qui leur permettrait de de
provoquer un coup comme g2 g3 ou f3 f4
qui serait responsable puisque les nous
les blancs abandonnerait donc certaines
cases au centre et affaiblir un petit
peu plus les droits donc avec le coup
fourré suite en d6 exactement on
explique un tout petit peu donc aussi
dans cette position de lait noir avec
cette structure donc des 5 c 6 2 6 ce
garde à n'importe quel moment la
possibilité donc de réagir au centre
ils ont un sens très solide ils tiennent
leur structure de pions et en même temps
ils peuvent réagir à n'importe quel
moment ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
puisque ils sont moins bien développée
là pour l'instant les noirs doivent
choisir donc leur stratégie pour placer
le roi noir quand qu'en penses-tu font
certainement choisir le grand roque non
ça paraît plus plus sûr ici pour les
noirs non oui donc le grand roque est
possible mais je pense que lors on va
peut-être dans cette position de
développer sont fous sont fous le fou f8
peut-être le placer en 10 600 avoir peur
du coup c4 c5 puisqu'il pourrait glisser
le coup intermédiaire d'un grand dam
tout simplement vous et 6 mais bon
peut-être fausse est aussi fawcett n'est
pas n'est pas plus mal on voit laurent
frayssinet bien concentré avec sa main
sur le menton je pense que l'on est
freyssinet concentré puisque cette
position ne sait plus joué depuis un
petit moment et que joël a probablement
préparé quelque chose donc laurent fois
ci ne veut pas se dépêcher à ce moment
là c'est le moment important pour
choisir un bon plan et oui je vous fous
dit voilà donc fou des six noms qui tape
sur le pion h 2 notez qu'à une petite
combinaison si les plats en joue le coup
c4 c5 attaquant à la fois la dernier le
fou il est noir peuvent jouer d'abord
dame frêle dame suivie peut-être de
fourrage 2 donc laurent qui a levé les
yeux vers la cabine je n'espère qui
j'espère qu'il ne m'entends pas voilà
donc h3c liège où elle donc a affaibli
légèrement donc son endroit
oui les cases noires ici notamment un
casier 3 est affaibli exactement dont
elles peuvent être une classe pour
lecavalier 6 types lecavalier m6 qui
pourrait bondir de sur la case sur la
case h5 plus tard je ne sais pas s'il va
le faire immédiatement puisque si il
joue s'il commence immédiatement par
cavalier f6 h5 les noirs pourraient
peut-être les blancs pourraient
peut-être tout simplement développer
leur fief en d3 et le cavalier angers
trois attaques à la tour mais la tour
irait sur la case de 1 et
et on comprendrait pas trop la stratégie
des noirs dans cette position puisque le
cavalier aurait joué deux coups pas très
utile alors que les blancs auraient
terminé leur développement
voilà donc h2 et h3 c'est tout noir de
réfléchir une question ou warocqué
laurent frayssinet s'il rompt fait petit
rock
dans ce cas les pions blancs h3 et g2 ne
demande qu'à être poussées et s'ils
auront fait grand roque donc ce qui est
plus probable
dans ces cas-là on imagine mal joël
pousser les pions devant son roi pour
attaquer droit adverse
donc ce qui est très important c'est de
choisir le camp le plus solide et voilà
donc grand roque le coup le plus logique
quand de laurent frayssinet il a réussi
à lier ces tours le développement est
terminé maintenant ça va être l'heure de
passer à des plans constructif un plan
un plan intéressant pour les blancs
c'est certainement chez pas ce que vous
en pensez serwa b1 bouger le roi pour
pour laisser passer un jour la tour d 1
sur la cas c'est un
effectivement finir le développement du
foot est fait ce que vous en pensez
oui donc dans cette position joue elle a
tout intérêt à continuer son
développement voilà donc dame ces deux
dames c2 qui menace ses 4 c 5 1 en a
gagné une pièce menacé car ces scènes
qui attaquent la dame et le fou voilà
donc joël qui qui sort donc une idée
personnelle une idée préparer donc dans
cette position lors on va peut-être
devoir ramener la dame b 6 ans et 7 et
donc ce serait se seraient à peu près la
même chose
on rappelle que de toute façon sur dams
b 6 et 7 je ne pense pas que le coût que
le coup c4 c5 soit si dangereux que ça
mais c'est peut-être possible il faut
quand même se méfier donc joël qui joue
un coup un petit peu un petit peu
nouveau et là sur dame b3 ces deux
peut-être que l'auront dans cette
position peut essayer de réagir au
centre je ne sais pas peut-être qu'il
peut jouer donc des cinq prend ses 4
suivi de cavaliers des cinq mais je n'en
suis pas sûr puisque dans ces cas-là il
abandonnerait il abandon un petit peu le
centre non lors on ramène la dame c'est
plus solide c'est plus dans son style il
a ramené la dame sur la casse et 7
il garde cette structure de pion à
laquelle il a extrêmement confiance donc
la structure des 5 c si c'est aussi ce
qui est très très solide à noter que
peut-être le coup aux quatre peut être
envisagée pour les blancs de 3,4 pour
faire la pression maximale sur le pion
des 5 avec d'options qui attaqueraient
oui donc menacé aussi 4,5 donc sur trois
ou quatre on peut on peut envisager donc
le coup fou des six f4 peut-être donc
pour éliminer ce fou de
ce fou de cases blanches se serait
peut-être envisageable donc fou des six
f4 ou ou une réaction centrale peut-être
donc une réaction centrale qui
pourraient arriver après peut-être pions
prend 4 suivi de
2 e 6 e 5 pour essayer d'obtenir les
cases noires ou deux c6 c5
non c'est si ça ce n'est pas possible
donc tokyo 4 5 qui menacent exactement
voilà ça devient un peu tendu là
peut-être le coût à 3 4 qui mettrait une
grosse pression sur le centre de
réfléchir jouer le luthier peut-être il
veut terminer son développement aussi
jouer peut-être fou des 3 suivi de tours
h 20 avant de jouer il a joué en pro b
1b je suis content et je reviens il veut
peut-être effectivement comme dit
bertrand mètres la tour sur le cas c'est
un
et avec la dame faire pression sur la
colonne c'est oui et de toute façon
comme je l'expliqué après que trois ou
quatre il y avait peut-être le coup des
six f4 pour échanger les fous et donc
obtenir les cases noires en compensation
après roy bien sûr il peut peut-être
préparer plus sérieusement le coup eux
quatre
car le coût food et 6 6 4 ne saurait
serait beaucoup moins gênant à cause de
fous des deux ans à tours c'est un tour
c'est un donc les joueurs qui qui joue
qui joue un match assez fond de court
puisqu'il joue beaucoup de manoeuvres de
pièces avant de prendre des décisions au
centre comme tout à l'heure et huit
robes et 8 et tour des seins c'est un tu
appelle ça un jeune fond de court alors
qu'apple arrête eu un jeu à la volée
exactement à je la vole et ben on va
voir plus tard on espère que orbite de
départage il y aura je la vole et s'il
est on rappelle donc que si les joueurs
font match nul s'ils font un partout où
ils vont jouer donc un blitz de
départage et ça sera la volée ça sera
probable beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
rapide et avec peut-être plus de fautes
mais en même temps plus de spectacle
enfin plus de deux tactiques de
pirouette on va dire cette position elle
recèle encore beaucoup de poster
beaucoup plus de possibilités que la
précédente
ah oui donc position évidemment donc la
raison principale c'est que c'est que
très peu de pièces ont été changées dans
cette position un cavalier contre un fou
seulement il reste toutes les pièces
donc forcément la position est
extrêmement complexe
en plus c'est ce qu'on peut dire que
cette position et est souple puisque les
possibilités centrales sont multiples
donc les blancs ont la possibilité
d'installer trois pions au centre par
eux deux trois ou quatre auquel cas les
les noirs devraient réagir assez assez
assez violemment et ils ont aussi la
possibilité donc 2
de jouer d'autres coups mais je crois
que le groupe principal dans cette
position c'est surtout 3e cat mais sur
trois ou quatre je suppose que laurent
frayssinet va probablement prendre en c4
et essayer après d'échangés ce pion des
quatre part peut-être aussi ce 5 afin de
afin d'éliminer donc toutes les tous les
pions centraux et de s'installer après
sur la colonne des avec ses avec sa tour
et de faire jouer ses cavaliers donc un
plan à long terme mais un plan assez
envisageable bon il se trouve que
l'auront dans cette position doit placer
ses pièces utilement dans ce but et là
il n'a pas il n'a pas énormément de deux
choix facile à faire puisque ces
cavaliers sont très bien placés sur ces
cases là le foin des 6 également et très
très bien placé laurent fasciné peut
doit peut-être prendre ces quatre dans
cette position cette province et 4 il
doit peut-être prendre ces 4 et après
fou prend ses quatre peut-être essayé de
réagir par e 6 e 5 à ce n'est
malheureusement pas possible puisqu'il
puisqu'elle pions f7 en prison qu'il
devrait commencer probablement par
cavalier 17 b 6 suivi 2 e 6 e 5 donc on
est décédé si ce n'est pas possible on
prend ces quatre d'abord faux procès
quatre cavaliers 17 b 6 et aussi ce sens
l'idée dans cette position jean luc
c'est donc d'essayer pour les noirs de
se libérer au centre c'est bien ça
exactement des surge en faisant quelques
gens j'ai essayé s'est donné un peu
d'air parce qu'ils ont quand même un peu
un peu moins d espace que les blancs oui
tout à fait donc les noirs qui ont
intérêt à échanger un petit peu donc un
petit peu un petit peu quelques pièces
au centre pour pour donner un peu d'air
à leurs cavaliers et puisque là ils sont
quand même un petit peu resserré sur six
rangées leurs pièces qui sont un petit
peu à l'étroit pour l'instant mais qui
ne demande qu'à jouer puisque
puisqu'elles sont quand même toutefois
bien placé il y a un coût intéressant
aussi dans cette position que laurent
peut jouer à quoi c'est assez curieux
c'est le coup j'ai 6 g sainte avec donc
le coup j'ai six g5 qui serait donc tout
simplement dans le but de lancer une
petite initiative donc allé droit et
d'essayer de fixer un petit peu donc ses
pions ses pions affaibli donc de
toujours contrôler les certaine qu'à
stratégique a les droits
c'est un choix assez intéressant par
exemple donc sur eux trois ou quatre
après après g6 g5 l'euro aurait
peut-être la possibilité donc de poser
son fou des 600 f 4 comme tout à l'heure
comme on l'a signalé saddam c7 serait
donc n'aurait pas besoin de défendre ce
fou et il pourrait plus tard venir avec
ce cavalier f6 sur les cases noires
affaibli bbc met donc laurent a joué le
premier choix donc été enseignante
survie cavaliers b6 au prince et qu'avec
des si voilà donc voilà qui laisse aux
blancs deux pions centraux 3 et des
quatre contre un seul pour les noirs le
pion aux six dont une majorité centrale
pour les blancs mon fils finalement on
se comporte bien c'est que le/la la
méthode de liquidation de jean luc est
assez classique c'est à dire on prend
ces dissidents joueurs de position
on échange et on essaye de libérer ces
pièces c'est un moyen quand même
relativement classique qu'est ce que tu
peux en oui c'est un moyen relativement
classique donc
à la seule différence c'est que dans les
positions classiques avec le petit rock
de chaque côté on joue en général c6 c5
dans cette position je pense que les
noirs ont plutôt joué le pion est dans
cette position le pion aux six ans le 5
c'est le coup le plus intéressant est
conservé ce plan syscom comme barrière
naturelle donc barrière défensive pour
le roi noir c'est quand même ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que finalement les deux
joueurs ici et ça c'est très important
font un effort stratégiques c'est-à-dire
que ils font bien attention aux centres
aims to de ces dernières manoeuvres ont
pour but de se libérer au sein de
l'échiquier prend dans ses 4 quand on
vient de le voir jouer cavalier b6 qui
gagne un temps sur l' attaque du fou en
c4 et après certainement joué cinq tout
ça pour ouvrir la position
et donner de l'air un peu à ces pièces
exactement donc les intérêts maintenant
c'est que la dame c7 protège le pion au
fcl
donc si le four recul dans la classe b 3
on peut jouer aussi sur scène c'est ce
que souligne donc à travers le
commentaire de notre ami stéphane c'est
la libération des pièces noires qui
était engoncé qui manquait des espaces
il ya de ça quelques instants qui d'un
seul coup on beaucoup plus de
possibilités
oui donc les noirs qui qui pour
l'instant donc si on va évaluer la
position d'une position tout à fait
tenable dans une position très très très
tout à fait équilibré et d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs je jouais dans cette position
à quelques soucis semble-t-il alors
c'est assez important de dire c'est que
tu connais très bien jean luc laurent
puisque vous êtes vous êtes très très
copains alors est-ce qu'il a quand même
pas eu beaucoup de chance en tirant joël
qui comme le grand favori de ce tournoi
au premier tour mais visiblement il s'en
sort bien là quand même hein il a l'air
de jouer très très sérieusement mon
solidement mais faut c'est ce qu'il faut
faire contre un champion comme joël oui
on aura joué le foot est roi et où cinq
jeux secs a été jouée je joue elle qui
qui donc le luron freyssinet qui joue
une position qu'il connaît extrêmement
bien donc
cette position lui a rendu des services
à plusieurs fois plusieurs reprises et
dans cette dans cette configuration il
et il est probablement aussi fort que je
jouais les cette position qui les
maîtrisent donc c'est probablement la
pression qu'il connaît le mieux aux
échecs et avec avec donc avec ça
sa vivacité il est capable il est
capable de faire quelque chose alors le
seul avantage maintenant si on pouvait
parler davantage pour joël c'est la
fameuse paire de fou alors peut-être que
tu nous dises quelques mots sur cet
avantage qui est pas souvent d'ailleurs
bien compris des amateurs qui préfèrent
les cavaliers ici donc les les blancs
ont de fou alors que les noirs 2
n'ont qu'un seul est ce que ça peu dans
cette position être un avantage à court
terme voie lente à long terme
oui dans cette position ce sera
probablement un avantage à long terme
puisque donc la paire de fou la paire de
fou donc pourrait jouer si si les pièces
échangées et que la position s'ouvre est
bon il se trouve actuellement ce n'est
pas vraiment une paire de fou
extraordinaire puisque le fou des deux
est quand même un petit peu un museau
les mains petit peu museler puisqu'il
n'a qu'une seule petite case la case 2 1
voilà donc
et muselé temps le terme très juste pour
cette raison joël d'ailleurs joué
cavalier e 2 donc il libère la colonne
c'est pour ces pièces lourdes
il donne un petit peu plus d espace à
s'en fout des deux et en même temps il
s'apprête probablement à reprendre
peut-être du cavalier sur des cats donc
le cavalier qui trouvera un avant-poste
plus utile donc un coût très logique
mais pour un t2 qui devrait venir sur la
case à 5 pour clouer le club et libé 6
alors gardons pour l'instant la position
qui reste vraiment sans surprise c'est
vraiment une position extrêmement
classique
donc là on peut peut-être envisager donc
c'est vrai on peut peut-être envisager
donc pions prend des cats adams est
d'abord widom et c'est donc la dame mais
qui qui équipe cette case dans ses sets
où elle était une sorte de refuge où
elle ne servait pas à grand chose
le fou le fou des six donc peuvent eux
peuvent venir donc sur plusieurs cases
et la dame vient sur la colonne eux qui
va s'ouvrir probablement alors
maintenant il n'y a plus qu'une seule
pièce qui n'a pas été joué chez les
blancs il faut pas oublier le
développement c'est la torah juin
non tu la mets ou jean-luc alors la
question c'est que faut-il à bouger tout
de suite ou faut-il prendre au centre
peut-être avec ce pion des c'est
compliqué c'est quand même assez
compliqué ou peut-être pousser le pieu
ans ou quatre il ya plusieurs
possibilités
si je devais développer cette tour
probablement la mettrait en d1 en d1 où
on donc les deux possibilités pour cette
tour donc c'est vrai il n'y a pas de
grosse surprise mais je vais laurent il
a joué que quatre coups sûrs en prenant
la voilà donc voilà ça c'est un coût qui
entourent hd1 il échoué tour un des 1
joël et laurent a répondu par eux quatre
ans surprenant mais l'idée c'est un
ferme et se fout des noeuds on va
essayer maintenant pris par ses propres
pions exactement donc l'idée l'idée de
laurent est enfermé le fou des deux mais
c'est aussi de fixer le pion 3 donc leur
ont fait signer qui fait plus que tenir
la position dans cette position et il ya
en même temps il fixe puis à une manette
il ya donc une menace serait bon qu on
prend un f3 suivi de tout reproche je
crois qu'ils gagneraient un pion alors
là ça c'est un coup ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle une position critique un sac là
va falloir faire qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que peut bien faire je vais le lotier là
dessus a priori prendre un café avec le
pion cet idiot parce que ça permettrait
aux cavaliers et six de reprendre et
d'avoine position centrale fantastique
et jouer f3 f4
c'est pas un coup qu'on a envie de faire
ça la beauté noire c'est de prendre et
bien sûr mais et en cas de reprise du
pion c'est la torah je suis elle
viendrait gober le pian h3 donc
l'heureux joël qui a peut-être à sa
disposition à ses fils deux pions il
peut peut-être joué cavalier eux deux
ces trois pour essayer de renforcer le
centre et si le pion aux 4 prend effet 3
il reprend dû plonger donc ils ramènent
un pion vers le centre mais surtout
quand je crois donc surtout empreinte 3
il aurait peut-être la possibilité de
jouer deux trois ou quatre qui
menacerait donc que 4,5 pour gagner une
pièce est donc en échange du pion il
aurait il aura un fort centre c'est une
possibilité intéressante mais quand même
assez complexe si risqué à ces risques
est exactement mais dans cette position
leur on joue de manière très très
opportuniste et échoue elle va devoir
être très précis avec les blancs à noter
aussi que si les blancs jouent f3 f4
maintenant après les noirs en super 15
en d5 ils peuvent venir avec leur
cavalier sur la caisse des cinq peuvent
pas la garde et bien longtemps et parce
que je vois qu'il y ait ces trois très
vite non après f3 f4 donc le cavalier m6
vient sur la case des 5es et là je pense
que les noirs on continue quand même
position très intéressante soit tu
prends souvent basculer à la casse b4
alors là donc ça veut dire jean-luc que
tu penses que que les noirs sont un peu
mieux
tout dépend des conséquences du
sacrifice de pions que j'ai proposé tout
à l'heure bon il faut peut-être que tu
leur expliques parce qu'il était un peu
compliqué donc l'heureux le sacrifice de
pions pourrait survenir après cavaliers
e2c 3 alors on va le montrer le cavalier
le déficit pourrait venir sur la casse
ces trois attaquants le pion à eux
quatre
voilà donc et sur le pion sur la prise
du pion aux gars tu enlèves 3g prend f3
pour prendre 3 et de 3 e 4 avec un gros
centre alors la question que je me pose
donc actuellement c'est aussi qu'est ce
qui se passe après un coup hibbert
réaliste comme f3 prend le cas tout
simplement f3 prendre 4 donc voilà donc
on ne veut pas perdre deux pions alors
on
tout simplement on prend le pion à eux
cinq et cavaliers prend 1,4 probablement
cavaliers prend 1,4 c'est vrai que cette
position semble quand même difficile
pour les pour les blancs le cavalier
roccat et à un avant-poste fantastique
le pion aux trois derrière est affaibli
et c'est là que tu as raison en france
elle a peut-être la situation parce
qu'après on peut jouer cavalier c3 aussi
avec les blancs et et finalement à
lenval autre concept sera donc vous
aviez déjà parlé tout à l'heure c'est
que le fou en d2 est un mauvais fond
dans celle d'un donc de 2 reste combien
de temps en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que voilà on l'a on a vraiment une
position critique parce que les deux
joueurs enfin saute surtout joël dans
cette position prend du temps parce que
il sait que c'est réellement dans ce
genre de position qu'on peut prendre
qu'on peut perdre une partie ou qu'on
peut la gagner d'ailleurs un wii se
passe il se passe des choses très
compliquées à cet instant de la partie
et c'est vrai que bon moi je vous savez
que jean-luc chabanon viens viens viens
d'obtenir sa troisième fois restaurée
fin donc je rêve qui a trouvé une autre
solution une solution intéressante
également c'est que ok sur la prise en
f3 il va reprendre de la tour et c'est
vrai que le pion à eux est un petit peu
arriérée un petit peu faible puis en
trois après le pion blanc mais la tour f
3 va défendre ce pion de 3 et en même
temps elle va exercer une pression
intéressante sur la colonne f
donc voilà l'idée ce qui fait que le
cavalier f6 ne pourrait pas bondir sur
la case centrale ucac puisque le pion à
vii centre est immédiatement
voilà donc touré fin un autre coup très
très logique donc joël qui plutôt que de
sacrifier un pion et de rentrer dans des
complications choisi la voie de la
sagesse c'est à villena ci menace puis
on prend 1,4 c'est à dire donc voilà
donc consolider sa position toujours une
menace qui en prend 1,4 joël donc le
rend facile dans cette position va
peut-être c'est vrai que comme une
menace sur prague et il va peut-être
prendre f3 et après essayer de boucher
la diagonale b3g 8 enfin la démo net du
four b3 part
par un coup de cavaliers peut-être par
le cavalier b6 ses dix ans je m'ai
quelques coups là ils ont joué de jouer
cavalier bechis en d5 dans cavalli b6
des cinq d'abord c'était très judicieux
avant de prendre 3 et la 4 f 4 voilà
donc f4 très logique on va très vite
très joué très logique maintenant f4
puisque donc de toutes façons le pion et
trois étaient fixés et la configuration
donc des cavaliers en bref si sûr des
cinq n'est pas la meilleure sur la
poussée du tournoi 4 il faudrait mieux
que lecavalier que l'autre cavaliers
soit soit en d5 et que le cavaly soir b6
auquel cas les noirs pourraient réagir
plus rapidement à l'étroit et on en est
ou à la lapin de stéphane là tu sais et
bien non je ne sais pas je n'arrive pas
à voir on voit pas très bien non ça
c'est de la cabine
j'ai l'impression que les blancs il
reste que je crois en 9 minutes hawks
minutes au la langue ça contredit son or
voilà nos peurs mais ça va forcément ça
va jouer sur la à cette position
compliquée ça arrive de jouer comme le
temps voilà donc laurent frayssinet qui
qui s'apprête probablement à ouvrir la
position il prépare donc la dame et en
c2 il prépare peut-être la poussée c6 c5
maintenant ce qui lui permettrait donc
d'attaquer plus plus plus facilement
donc la dame en c2 va se retrouver mal
placé il va falloir bouger un petit peu
cette diagonale peut-être cavaliers eux
deux ces trois rois roanne
quel coût on dirait un coup d' atteinte
on dirait un coût d'attenté ça c'est un
coup curieux roi parce que ça mais le
roi en position de maths du couloir
alors qu'il ne l'était pas et laurent
frayssinet réagi tout de suite par ses
six essais naim et le feu l'échiquier
laurent fait signer là notre ami
le bordelais stéphane laborde iv le feu
à l échiquier ils menacent de prendre un
des quatre est de gagner pions puisque
la tour c 8 attaquerez la dame donc leur
offre ici nati qui se prend la tête là
se prend carrément la tête sur
l'échiquier et qui est très déterminé ça
ce sont alors ses 6 et 5
maintenant que va répondre joël sur ceux
sur cette offensive est peut-être qu'il
va ramener la dame en b1 timidement jeu
pour justifier roire et permettre
finalement un échange général des tours
ce qui lui permettrait de tenir la
position alors on rappelle que dans
cette position-là père de fous ne joue
pas énormément puisque le fou des deux
ne joue toujours pas dans sa position et
il risque de ne pas trop jouer puisque
un cavalier en des cinq attaquants
constamment le curieux 3 va leva le
fixer sur cette caste des de tout
simplement pas maintenant maintenant
vous pensé quand même que les noirs sont
mieux il semblerait que les noirs sont
blancs les noirs sont mis depuis depuis
quelques coups depuis quelques coups
depuis le coup de 4 semblerait que
laurent frayssinet réussi à mettre la
pression dans l'esprit de la position
voilà donc peut-être que aussi joël n'a
pas eu envie de sacrifier un pion
puisqu'après eux quatre ils avaient la
possibilité quand même d'essayer de
jouer avec ses pièces c'était nécessaire
et lisa c'est toi qui aimes sacrifier
les pions
oui mais il ya un joueur qui a fait de
très beau sacrifice et qui c'est qui ces
kasparov alors j'espère off qui jouent
des partis assez ces sauvages parfois
est ce que est ce qu'un jour kaspar
reviendra aux grands-prés lucienne à
canal web
il est venu l'an passé pour présenter
son émission dame c4 voilà donc joël qui
est tout surprenant donc non pas tant
que ça puisque la dame veut rentrer dans
l'action sa position sur pions prompt
sur pied au cours des quatre jours elle
va probablement reprendre de la dame
avéré le choix il faudra reprendre la
dame
oui mais c'est avant tout la dame sera
centralisé et il a une petite parade afu
ses seins qui attaqueraient la dame se
serait peut-être le coup le ku'damm des
4 e 5 échecs
voilà donc ces cinq dames c4 c'est
qu'est-ce que tu repenses ces lois n'ont
rien pour le moment c'est très compliqué
mais j'aime bien la position de laurent
frayssinet alors content il reste assez
difficile à lire on dirait que la 7
minutes aux blancs contre 8 minutes 30
au noir c'est assez bien d'être jouée à
6 alors là peut-être pour jouer p5 et
oui les normes jouer b5 menaçant c4 ont
brillamment complètement le fou de cases
blanches par exemple oui donc le pour
l'instant le challenge stratégique c'est
simplement donc l'activité des pièces
joël qui qui est qui qui s'est vu un
petit peu contre et stratégiquement
puisque champions 2 3 fx est donc mais
bien attaqué par un cavalier centrale
essaye de faire rentrer saddam dans
l'action et la leur on commence à
contrôler ses cases sac l'attention mais
là la menace bessette b5 et mortelle
pratiquement nos clips ofac et shaft
entre sa dame acat damas quatre donc
damas quatre le coup logique pour éviter
baisse est de 5 puisque la dame contre
le pion en a six ans la sueur bessengue
maintenant la dame peut prendre le pion
à 6 voilà donc damas cat est clairement
l'initiative du côté noir
il a joué laurent on dire qu'elle joue
gros à 7 et oui il veut quand même joué
le bessin il protège le pion à 6 avec
100 voix et une menace de jouer b5 et
oui et la dame en a quatre qui se
retrouve finalement mal placé elle se
retrouve mal placé cette dame ficelé
damasco dame
cette dame donc le roi à cette idée fond
la partie va se terminer de manière
incroyable c'est violent l'aller le rend
facile et a réussi à prendre l'aventage
sont jouées le lotier c'est clair
maintenant est ce que ça sera suffisant
pour wiimote et la partie attention
alors autant il reste combien de temps
eh bien je ne vois pas du tout
malheureusement
moi non plus c'est difficile d'avoir
bien joué et bien joué il a joué pions
prince et 5
donc je pense c'est 5 c'est nécessaire
il faut ouvrir la position finalement il
a obligé il a obligé les blancs apprend
dans ses cinq grands fasciné on voit
assez précis là il va sûrement reprendre
du foot faisait en mettant une pression
sur le pion aux 3 jean-luc et oui donc
c'est la stratégie depuis le début de
cette partie donc essayer de fixer ce
pion ce pion aux trois depuis la fin de
l'ouverture
et maintenant donc laurent se rapproche
de cette stratégie mais la position
s'ouvre donc il va falloir être vigilant
puisque maintenant les fous peuvent
peuvent commencer à jouer
alors peut-être que que je jouais là
intérêt donc à échanger peut-être le
cavalier en d5 avec son four b3 on joue
au foot pour cavaliers a fait 56 5
alalalala grosse pression maintenant
puisque le fou csii menace de prendre
trois protégés par le cavalier des cinq
exactement donc peut-être que les blancs
dans cette position vont jouer fou à
cavaliers des cats
car il des quatre voilà qui protège et
on dirait que la dame et la dame blanche
presque prise assure b5 halak une case
exactement mais c'est surtout sur
cavaliers b6 sauf cavaliers b6 aussi
elle a aussi mis gazon à 5 / b cinq
cavaliers pro b 5e les scènes calmes en
revanche et cavaliers b6 et un coup
dangereux oui c'est un coup dangereux
voilà donc cavalier b6 qui est très
intéressant et sur cavaliers des cinq
échecs les noirs pourrait ramener tout
simplement le roi en b 8 donc sûr
qu'avec b6 probablement dame à 5 et que
pensez vous d'un coup comme tour à geler
huit dont le tournage débute arrière
plus solides quand même vague
c'est ce qui était joué mais c'est ce
qu'il a joué effectivement bien vu
bertrand 3 g 8 qui contrôle totalement
le centre laurent frayssinet il verra
maintenant plein de combinaisons à base
de cavaliers pro f catabase de cavaliers
prend et 3
cette position alors qu'en penses-tu
jean-luc la wii donc hélas pour
l'instant on va te préfère plutôt jouer
ça avec avec les noirs général c'est
très compliqué donc c'est vrai que le
jeu de pièces noires est très très
agréable mais oui évident c'est vrai que
les unes des noirs ont un jeu de pièces
assez incroyable dans cette d'un sens et
les mains donc laurent frayssinet qui en
général donc je joue ses semis slave qui
ouvre la position et qui finalement
après avoir ouvert la position fait
jouer ses pièces puisque finalement donc
c'est un joueur tactique c'est un joueur
très agressif qui se révèle plutôt assez
tard dans la partie puisqu'il commence
par départ des débuts très très solide
mais qui n'a qu'une seule envie c'est de
faire jouer ses pièces est d'ailleurs
actuellement il commença les allées les
années tous dans l'action hélas il a
joué autour des 1 oui joël qui défend ça
se sent donc il remet ses pièces vers
les cases
là on a la niaque ans a volé par 4 qui
semblerait qu avant l épreuve 4 à l'air
de être possible cavalière et peut-être
aussi amélioré cavaliers b5 et shaktoi
cavaliers b5 échec donc la position
reste très compliqué ça reste égal quand
même ça reste difficilement non mais
peut-être que la manoeuvre que il a joué
laurent il a joué coupé seafood et si
fou b65 ou de repli oui donc un coût
très logique là luron qui qui qui n'est
pas obligé de provoquer les événements
dans cette position donc donne un petit
peu plus de possibilités à saddam
recettes en même temps donc il peut et
échanger les tours et
donc il défend bien son roi dans sa
position et et c'est bien les charges et
une perte de tous ses pièces restent
toujours très bien placé
voilà donc on échange d'une tour et
maintenant que va faire que va faire
joël donc la dame aurait 4 semble un
petit peu toujours mal placé ça c'est le
problème de joël et se font des deux
évidemment se font des deux qui ne serra
qui ne sert pas à grand chose pour
laisser passer un gros pions pour
l'instant se fout c'est un gros pions
qui protège le pian 2 3 la partie modèle
sur comment museler la paire de fou
voilà mais bon il faut quand même
signaler que je suis qu'à présent joue
elle a très bien défendu
il a très bien défendu et en même temps
il y à toutes les possibilités pour pour
contrer le jeu de laurent donc ont
finalement un match assez curieux
puisque on y sent que que les blancs
n'obtiennent pas grand chose dans
l'ouverture et que c'est plutôt les
noirs qui font le jeu ce qui est plutôt
l'opposé donc habituellement aux échecs
la partie reste très tendue à fou à cinq
a été jouée x 5 donc est-ce que ça perd
pas le pion à 3 on peut peut-être
prendre le pur le 3 mai dans ces cas là
donc après fonds à cinq je suppose
moi il faut près 1,5 d'abord et on
prendrait le client est roi oui ce
serait peut-être possible mais il faut
quand même se méfier puisque les noirs
ont les planches de pièces ça c'est
assez intéressant par exemple on
pourrait envisager donc au lycée trois
fois cinq cavaliers ces trois cas les c3
and only a été joué à d'abord non
cavalli c3 une belle combinaison
voilà donc laurent fossiles et qui
gagnent les qualités essayez donc
laurent fascine et qui n'ont mais il ay
d'avoir été jouer autre chose
cavalier ces deux d'abord qu'est-ce qui
a été joué
à la poêle
alors là on va revenir à l'échiquier
réel parce que là ça commence à jouer
très vite
voilà que maintenant la laurent
frayssinet a réussi à prendre la qualité
il a une tour contre une pièce mineurs
il a fait une combinaison laurent
frayssinet il a joué un coup superbe
qu'avait laissé 3 il est mieux laurent
là il est mieux il peut gagner la partie
donc laurent qui a finalement concrétisé
son avantage sont davantage
positionnelle en avantages matériels
mais donc il faudrait en savoir un petit
peu plus sur le temps puisque maintenant
donc tout va se jouer à la pendule dame
sekkat attaque le pion f7 donc là
l'auront qui est quand même très très
bien parti pour gagner ce match
oui menace de gagner la partie en
accrochant aux cavaliers des trois
échecs exactement donc laurent
frayssinet qui menacent maintenant de
coûts cavaliers des trois échecs et tour
d un échec et mat 3ca le seul coup alors
la ccir et là c'est chaud mais on croit
sert un coup intéressant puisque si la
tour quitté la colonne des la dame
pourrait peut-être s'installer en des
gâtée chloé cavaliers c5 pour retarder
les événements donc là pour l'instant
laurent qui doit résoudre quelques
petits problèmes tactiques
je vais d'indécise d'anne decis c'est
très bien donc il défend sa tour en même
temps il
il évite des possibilités de fourchette
par cavalier p4 suivi de d5
donc voilà qu'à valider quatre tours
h-2a joël qui est vraiment très très
inquiété dans cette position
puisque le roi de joël et d'extrêmement
est extrêmement on dire en insécurité
totale puisque la seconde rangée étant
contrôlé par la tourache 2 il ne
faudrait plus qu'à la dame la dame noire
donc il ne faudrait plus qu'à trouver le
chemin de la première rangée pour faire
échec et mat
ouah ouah c'est un coup solide notre âme
et donc fou ces deux il peut jouer trois
sets pour replacer son roi mais il joue
f6 tout simplement pour protéger son
coeur aussi
ça y est le rookie nom qui veut qu'il
veut le mat la la dame en d6 pourrait
venir sur a3 donc le rang qui va
peut-être en d3 d'abord et à prévenir en
a trois avec la dame s'est c'est
quasiment gagnant maintenant donc on va
dire qu'on peut dire que l'euro va
probablement gagner cette partie
c'est incroyable donc laurent qui fait
kiffer l'exploit donc le premier exploit
donc laurent frayssinet donc le petit
borsalino de du sénat donc qui fada qui
rentre avec saddam et qui domine donc
joël c'est incroyable c'est incroyable
le talent de ce jeune joueur et ses
matelas
cavalier b3 donc arrivé 3 h un beau coup
logique et qui qui donne qui donne
quelques contres chance aux blancs
puisque la dame ccap peut venir sur des
quatre tours l2 sur échec je pense que
c'est séduisent
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué dans deux des six
lames décision pourrait donc laurent qui
ne prend aucun risque là ils préfèrent
contrôler le pion h3 va tomber
l'avantagent matériel est évident mais
doit tout de même faire attention
cavaliers des caraïbes revière le pet
les coûts joël évidemment ce que s'il
arrive à répéter les coups la partie est
nul oui mais ce serait ce serait
vraiment ce ne serait pas une bonne
stratégie de faire du dans cette
position là peut-être que lors on peut
tout simplement prendre le pion aux h3
donc tout reproche 3 et prendre mettre
le matériel je pense que damas trois est
très très fort mais bon voilà trois sets
ça continue ce n'est pas encore fait
donc laurent donc grand favori dans
cette position mais quand d'une
malheureusement la voit pas mais la
pendule donc nous on aimerait en savoir
minuad
ils s'enrichissent sur la pendule il
reste un peu plus de deux minutes au
noir contre 2 minutes aussi aux blancs à
peu près trois minutes
dans le premier set il a fait jouer
mesbah il se bat alors là c'est ce qu'on
appelle si joël gagne ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle une arnaque dans les jardins du
luxembourg
il faut savoir que ici s'il ya un
tournoi c'est parce que c'est c'est le
lieu où les où les blitz heures se
retrouvent chaque semaine aux beaux
jours pour pour s'amuser et voilà yahya
yahya gagne segunda b 6 menace m'attend
b1
donc voilà le rend facile et qui veut
forcer les chances des dames et voilà
donc ils auront qui peut échanger les
dames quand il veut maintenant donc il
n'a plus qu'à quatre ans pose est donc
dans une finale technique voilà il monte
le roi le roi noir est coupée ça va être
très très difficile pour joël
et oui donc joël qui pousse sont plongés
qui va essayer donc de tenir avec son
petit cavalier mais la leur on rit
exactement à 5 un coup très malin
puisque leur on prépare une majorité de
pions dont qui prépare un pion pas ces
allèles dame
il va pousser son pion pays bas joueront
ces cinq baies 5 à 4 pour avoir un pion
passer ça lui fera deux pions passé donc
le pion des et le pion à et là ça sera
très très difficile
joël qu'il ne se laisse pas faire don
qui lui donc pousse ses pions aussi
c'est vrai que je connais bien laurent
et j'ai l'impression que cette position
il ne va pas là il va la gagner puisque
c'est une finale technique et devrait
poser aucun problème
donc voilà le cavalier qui qui doit
attendre un petit peu voilà je voi qui
essaye de faire un obstacle au roi
adverse
en tout cas c'est une belle belle leçon
de la part des jeunes qui est pas bien
et qui est créé tous les tous les
problèmes au blanc au noir pour gagner
cette position quand même voilà donc
l'euro qui s'affiche est un pion qui
joue encore avec panache
probablement parce qu'il a l'intention
de rentrer avec son roi noir le roi qui
va se diriger de ces cinq sur c4 qui va
essayer de prendre le pion c3 ce qui
fait que donc joël qui veut chasser
cette tour de la seconde rangée mais
dans cette position lors on peut prendre
h trois tours f2
sur le deuxième but sinon l'euro qui n'a
pas joué pour l'instant
malheureusement malheureusement ça y est
on est revenu sur la bonne
il va ramasser tous les pions et wiltord
ou trois ils ramassent tous les pions
lorrain fasciné et oui jo elle qui est
très tenace et qui s'aiment d'embûches
donc le chemin de la victoire de laurent
fasciné puisque là c'est pas facile
c'est toujours pas si facile que ça mais
quand même c'est quand même c'est quand
même gagné donc l'art wade de une astuce
toujours sur tourcoing f4 ya une
fourchette donc laurent va probablement
le pion à cat
quand il prend jesse s'il a fait jouer
il est toujours il est toujours là
intentions parce qu'en plus
malheureusement voit pas la pendue et ça
va se jouer dans un secteur terrible
comme cette fin de partie
et oui donc jeu qui est toujours là donc
très difficile
mais bon on rappelle quand même qu'une
tour c'est plus fort qu'un cavalier et
oui parce que lecavalier quand même avec
ces petits bonds il peut pas traverser
chéquier très rapidement donc on va voir
ce que ce que va faire joël may et avec
des petits bancs donc eh oui je vais le
très tendue quand même pour cette cette
deuxième partie et oui oui oui oui et
oui
le pion g semble difficile à défendre
donc là
j'ai joué cinq est touché 4 a été jouée
par loin possible le valier fuite
tous les quatre cavaliers suisses tuner
ya encore une fourchette il faut
toujours des singles droit des 6 3 10 6
cavaliers aussi ce probablement annonc
avait lui aussi celle alors on va
peut-être jouer donc le coup j'ai six
encore cavaliers des quatre qui avaient
la catégorie 5
et oui oui oui cette position elle est l
est pas si facile à gagner
j'allais peut-être même pas gagné du
tout maintenant malheureusement
qu'en penses-tu jean-luc non je pense
que c'est encore une finale technique
gagnante avant oui puisque le pion c'est
va tomber il ya quand même un pion passé
toujours pour les noirs joël a très bien
défendu mais la position reste de toute
façon perdante c'est clair c'est clair
voilà donc c'est vrai cet échec c'est
clair mais
ah là là ça commence à devenir très
compliqué donc sur elle qui a pris la
bonne décision de monter son roi pour
accompagner les pions il s'apprête à
sacrifier le cavalier contre le pion
lors on doit éviter cela
ça y est ils y arrivent tous rêvent de
riche qu'à valider 6 voilà c'est très
dur pour les blancs d'arrêter le pion b
comment arrêter le pion b et oui ça y
est le pion arrive à dame
voilà donc le rond qui va bientôt gagner
cette partie
aimé peut jouer g7 là j'essaie de tout
projet s'est rangé c'est voilà c'est
fini
cette fois un moment où laurent fasciné
merci merci merci
alors donc superbe victoire de laurent
frayssinet qui a remporté le match donc
on va lui demander de dire un petit mot
sur cette deuxième partie alors laurent
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je crois qu'il
est une proposition nul que tu as refusé
à proposer nul donc bon on est au début
je mangeais plus très bien donc j'ai
essayé de trouver des coupes en moi même
et après je pense que je sais pas je
vais leur avenir mais je pense qu'après
qu'il b65 je pense que j'ai presque
égaliser déjà et après je pense qu'il a
raté e4 qui était un très fort coup et
tout de suite je pense que je prends un
petit peu l'initiative après je suis un
petit peu mieux
il a commencé à infléchir pour trouver
des coûts et donc le bon après il
restait moins de temps pour jouer des
coups donc même si la position est un
petit peu mieux pour moi et il lui
restait plus plus trop de temps donc il
a fait des imprécisions et un moment
quand je prends la qualité je pense que
je vois c'est évident que je
complètement gagnant et j'ai raté huit
fois des ventes plus simple et donc
finalement je pense que je suis toujours
gagner je suis toujours gagnant de la
finale mais bon j'ai j'ai l'impression
du temps j'ai très mal joué donc mais
bon je joue elle est un peu raté son
ouverture je pense donc j'ai mis du
temps un truc et b6 et 2,5 mais après ça
l'est oui donc on a tous vu évidemment
le coup qui a laissé 3 enfin je sais pas
je pense qu'on n'avait pas vraiment
prévu
c'était une surprise joël c'est le coup
que tu as raté c'était clairement pas
prévu
mais en fait oui j'étais déjà pas très
bien cette position a va dire c'est vrai
que 4 était très gênant j'ai joué tour d
un trop vite
vraiment un coup un peu un peu de
routine alors que j'aurais dû jouer
quelque chose comme des points 5
et en fait je pense que je suis un petit
peu mieux encore parce que j'ai deux
fous je le centre donc j'étais content
dans cette position mais après le casse
a complètement changé mais j'ai été trop
lents pour j'aurais dû jouer plus vite
toute façon mais mais de façon il a il a
très bien joué
irene tien d'accord et bien nous allons
bien je pense applaudir les deux joueurs
encore une fois on les remercie donc on
les retrouvera demain alors donc demain
laurent frayssinet sera en finale joël
lautier sera jouera le match pour la
troisième place donc leurs adversaires
seront désignés par le match qui va
suivre donc
ça sera à 17h30 donc je vous invite
éventuellement les faire un tour dans
les jardins du sénat qui sont très jolis
jardins du luxembourg ou alors à aller
vers saint michel qui est très sympa
aussi revenir en tout cas pour 17h30
pour voir cette fois ci le grand boris
spassky qui jouera la demi-finale contre
christian bauer on attend si vous êtes
sur internet
restez connectés puisque nous allons
vous montrer les meilleurs moments de
diagonale et donc
avec des reportages sur linares et des
interviews de kasparov & company et donc
je vous remercie je vous donne rendez
vous à 17h30